It’s big.
Yeah, it’s big.
This is on the big machine, right?
Yeah, this is on the big machine.
Drake with solar active.
Yeah.
So, if we were to take this outside and it
was sunny out…
Is this, which color is this?
It’s blue.
It would turn blue.
Immediately.
So we’re here today to look at the components
and units that have been completed for the
largest canopy, which is over 1,000 different
cells, 1,055 to be exact.
And then we’ll move on to the medium canopy.
And so Tom is taking us through the process
on their end and the knitting process is the
first stage in terms of the production.
The second stage will be the finishing and
the sewing of each of the units.
So to make this, we make this pattern
and each dot describes each stitch.
So, for example, this blue is programmed to
make a hole.
So we make this digital pattern and then this
is actual like language to the machine.
So then we transfer data to the machine.
And we feed the data and then, yeah that’s it.
So,  Lumen is composed of many, many parts and
just like in biology where surfaces and morphologies
are produced from single units, a cell networking
with its neighbor and it networking with its
neighbor to form larger surfaces.
Each one of these becomes a part of the canopy.
We may have, you know, 250 of these larges that all have the same circumference,
but then when they get finished into the nylon net, those circumferences change based on the pre-stress.
So this side will get sewn to its neighbor,
this side will get sewn to its neighbor,
this side will get sewn to its neighbor.
So it ends up forming a non-standard unit.
And I mean I find knitting so fascinating
on that level.
I mean you can look at the scale of that, right, to the scale of the canopy and there’s a hierarchy
that takes place in terms of how the material
assembly works.